la protection civile a une mission sur
plusieurs volets la première sur
l'action en action sociale on est
présent on continue les marottes une
social on est présent auprès d'un
agriculteur à ecully pour pouvoir
l'aider dans toutes les commandes et on
a également ce qui est la spécificité la
protection civile l'action sur le ce
point en effet nos équipes sont présents
depuis le début auprès du samu des
yvelines pour aller vers les manades à
domicile et pouvoir les transporter déjà
un fait relevé doute et éventuellement
d'aller les transporter sur les hôpitaux
du secteur à la demande
à la demande du samu nous avons
également en liaison avec les autorités
publiques des missions dans les ehpad 1
est différent opérations de logistique
par exemple dans les hôpitaux où un
accueil à la fois le public et on a une
mission de renfort dans les urgences
auprès des hôpitaux de poissy et mantes
la jolie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
habituellement la protection civile est
financé par de bienne le premier les
formations aux premiers secours qui
seront vendus auprès des entreprises des
collectivités mais aussi des
particuliers et ensuite des différents
dispositifs qu'elle vienne au secours
que l'on fait pour des organisateurs
privés ou des organisateurs public ses
activités à l'heure actuelle ce contrat
la ré conquête de ne pas parler demande
aussi du gouvernement puisqu'il n'ya
plus l'événement il n'y a plus de
formation aux premiers secours
à l'heure actuelle on a une demande
exponentielle de mission qu'il ya des
nouvelles missions qui vont se rajouter
à ça et c'est pour cette raison qu'on a
besoin de financements pour pouvoir
continuer ses missions la protection
civile à 99% depuis son existence n'a
pas pour habitude de se financer par la
générosité publique qui est un mot qui
est pour l'instant nous inconnu et qui
prend vraiment du sens pendant cette
histoire
[Musique]
alors la première possibilité la plus
simple c'est d'envoyer dons par sms ou
92 3 92 donc on en voit on envoie
simplement le don et ses 5 euros qui est
directement débité de sa facture
téléphonique de tous les opérateurs
jouent le jeu à l'exception de free
c'est important de deux cités si les
personnes qui souhaitent faire un don et
rencontrent des problèmes pour pouvoir
faire un don par sms où il souhaite tout
simplement donner plus de 5 euros
il suffit de se rendre sur le site
internet de la protection civile des
yvelines où ils ont l'occasion de faire
un don et s'ils préfèrent envoyer un
chèque ou par virement
ils nous contactent et on leur donnera
là bas réponses aux questions qu'ils se
posent pour pouvoir nous donner sachant
que l'ensemble des dons qui soit 2,5
euros et qui sera le plus sont
entièrement déductibles des impôts